[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous je dis 25 octobre
bienvenue sur tv 78 pour cette édition
du journal de la rédaction tout de suite
les titres de l'actualité locale
elle est l'une des trente lauréate de la
bourse l'oréal unesco pour les femmes en
sciences arts entier est originaire de
voisins-le-bretonneux cette post
doctorante au laboratoire de
l'accélérateur linéaire de l'université
paris-sud travail sur l'astronomie multi
messager elle est notre invité le réseau
s'étend sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines ski bus organisé une
journée à destination de ses salariés un
événement d'information sur la sécurité
routière rappelle des bons comportements
tests auditifs et de vision simulation
et d'accidents
et puis c'est la journée mondiale des
pâtes le plat et la base de
l'alimentation en italie les formes et
les modes de préparation varie selon les
régions
le chef de cuisine d'un restaurant de
montigny le bretonneux nous livrera à
quelques secrets de fabrication
1 mais avant de débuter les derniers
chiffres du chômage révélée ce matin au
troisième trimestre 2010 8,7 un recul
pour la catégorie a dans les yvelines -
ce mois 0,2 pour cent le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi s'établit à 65 mille
six cent sur un an au contraire le
chômage a augmenté de 0 4 point dans le
département promouvoir tous les sports
auprès des féminines c'est l'objectif de
sport en fit une opération lancée par le
comité olympique est régionale est la
session automne s'est achevée ce jeudi
et se dérouler cette semaine à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
environ 100 fille sont venus chaque jour
pour faire du sport ces jeunes ont entre
11 et 15 ans et viennent de quartiers
populaires elles ont tendance à
s'éloigner de la pratique sportive à
l'adolescence écoutez ses propos au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
on s'est aperçus dans les clubs que la
désaffection des jeunes filles étaient
plus marquée que celle des garçons
particulièrement à l'âge adolescent
puisque les jeunes jusqu'à une dizaine
d'années font facilement du sport filles
et garçons confondus
par contre à partir de
11 12 ans on se rend compte que les
jeunes filles grandissent forcément au
change physiquement mais aussi art est
le sport et nous on veut absolument que
la parité dans les clubs soit la fête et
que justement le plaisir de faire du
sport soit encore la partie centrale
j'allais dire de leurs activités
périscolaires ce programme a pour but de
favoriser les travaux les chercheuses et
d'en citer aussi les jeunes filles à se
tourner vers la science 30 femmes ont
été a distingué cette année par la
bourse l'oréal unesco parmi elles une
saint-quentinoise sarah entier bonsoir à
vous êtes originaire de
voisins-le-bretonneux vous êtes post
doctorante au sein du las le la halle
c'est le laboratoire de l'accélérateur
linéaire de l'université à paris sud
vous travaillez sur l'astronomie est
dite multi message et vous allez nous
expliquer tout ça dans un instant on
vous a donc décerné une bourse de
recherche vous allez également bénéficié
d'un programme de formation
complémentaire est ce que c'est une
fierté pour vous d'avoir été distingué
un merci tout d'abord de me recevoir
donc oui je suis très heureux d'avoir
obtenu la bourse l'oréal unesco pour les
femmes et la science 2018
puisque ça met en lumière en fait les
femmes dans le milieu scientifique en
particulier un astronome
donc c'est une fierté parce que pour ma
part en tant que jeune maman ça permet
de montrer qu'on peut avoir une carrière
scientifique et pas nous tout en étant
une jeune maman et j'espère que les
filles de notre département vont pouvoir
à leur tour embrasser une carrière
scientifique dans les sciences
fondamentales comme ce qui est mon cas
ce monde de la science aujourd'hui il
est essentiellement masculin pour la
part en astronomie oui il
essentiellement masculin je travaille
dans une collaboration européenne et
américaine où la part des femmes est à
peu près de 15%
et en ce qui concerne donc la
collaboration franco chinoises pour
laquelle je travaille on a à peu près
10%
donc oui il ya peu de femmes encore un
astre on va essayer de vulgariser au
possible le plus possible les travaux
aux travaux de recherche il concerne
donc l'astronomie dite multi messager
sur des phénomènes éphémère qui se
produisent dans l'espace alors ce sont
des travaux à l'avant garde car il
combine si j'ai bien compris des
informations transmises par la lumière
mais aussi par les ondes
gravitationnelles
c'est ça
et c'est donc l'astronomie multi message
est une nouvelle branche de l'astronomie
elle traite en fait des phénomènes très
violent de l'univers les plus violents
que l'on connaisse comme la collision de
trous noirs ou bien l'effondrement des
toiles très massive et donc l'idée c'est
qu'en plus de l'astronomie classique où
on peut avoir un signal lumineux
on a aussi accès au signal donné
gravitationnelle qui a été détecté pour
la première fois par la collaboration
d'un ego virgo en 2015 et donc une
déesse et de combiner l'information du
signal lumineux et du signal dont deux
graves nationale puisque le signale donc
gravitationnelle nous permet d'avoir
accès à des informations sur les
premiers instants là où la lumière ne ne
parvient pas et en 2015 on précise que
donc c'est des scientifiques de la
collaboration lago virgo qui ont ont
observé en fait pour la première fois
des ondes gravitationnelles lors d'une
collision entre deux trous noirs
exactement et ça a valu le prix nobel de
physique en 2017
au travers de trois chercheurs donc il
faut savoir que pour y détecter ces
ondes gravitationnelles il faut des
instruments extrêmement sensible on
appelle ça des interféromètres et pour
notre part la halle on est rattachée à
l'interféromètre virgo qui est en italie
qu'est-ce que ça ça permet toutes ces
informations vous recueillez c'est mieux
comprendre notre univers finalement ça
permet de mieux se rendre compte des
phénomènes extrêmement violent donc le
signal ou mais lumineux nous permet de
savoir plus sur l'environnement local où
la matière éjectée où les aimer les
éléments lourds qui ont été créés comme
par exemple lors comment on crée de l'or
tandis que le signale donc
gravitationnelle lui nous permet d'en
savoir plus sur par exemple les systèmes
les deux trous noirs en collision leur
mars
et c'est donc ça permet d'avoir une vue
d'ensemble sur ce phénomène violent et
par exemple quand je les dis ce qui nous
rattache plus
par exemple c'est de savoir l'origine de
l'or par exemple on n'avait pas d'idée
comment il pouvait être formé hélas lors
d'une découverte en 2017 qui a conduit
qui était en fait la collision de deux
étoiles à neutrons on a vu comment leur
pouvait être formée autour
au cours de cet événement ont connu une
évolution on l'a bien compris alors pour
vous aider dans cette observation vous
vous avez lancé par dont un projet dans
lequel vous associez des astronomes
amateurs exactement donc ce projet tout
d'abord il est professionnel
quand on le problème c'est que le
signale donc gravitationnelle est très
peu précis c'est à dire que sa position
dans le ciel est très imprécises pour
l'instant de ce fait pour identifier le
signal lumineux associés il faut un
grand nombre de télescopes qui observent
cette zone de recherches pour traquer le
signal lumineux associés et donc l'idée
qu'ont ces dix est bien c'est qu'on
s'est regroupée avec certains
laboratoires français mais aussi des
collaborateurs en chine en australie et
aux etats unis pour former un réseau de
télescopes robotique qui permet de
traquer le plus rapidement possible
l'agencé ces télescopes on les voit
actuellement l'immeuble voilà de traquer
le plus rapidement possible la
contrepartie est ce réseau s'appelle
grand mât donc comme je les dis il faut
avoir le plus de télescopes possible
puisque comme vous l'avez dit les
sources sont transitoires donc c'était
vraiment une course contre la montre
pour identifier et donc l'idée qui nous
est venue c'est d'associer les
astronomes amateurs qui peut rejoindre
notre notre projet les sites internet
qui s'affiche d'ailleurs exactement et
la campagne d'observation commençant à
partir de février 2019
donc si vous voulez rejoindre l'aventuré
avec nous soyez les bienvenus
et mettez vos coordonnées sur notre site
internet
le message est passé merci à sare entier
d'avoir été avec nous à chercheuse au
sein du lab de l'université paris sud et
vous êtes la lauréate l'une des
lauréates de la bourse l'oréal unesco
elle est la nouvelle rectrice de
l'académie de versailles charline avenel
40 ans a été nommé à ce poste hier
mercredi en conseil des ministres est la
secrétaire générale de sciences po
succède à daniel filâtre qui part à la
retraite
l académie de versailles englobe pour
rappel les départements des yvelines de
l'essonne à des hauts de seine et du val
d'oise
vérifiez sa vision revoir certaines
postures ou encore calculer son temps de
réactivité les salariés les salariés de
ski bus et cars perrier ont participé ce
jeudi à une journée de sensibilisation à
la sécurité routière
reportage de mélanie poquet si les
sourires sont toujours là c'est que ce
bus qui bascule est un outil pédagogique
un des ateliers d'une journée de
sensibilisation ski bus et cars périer
c'est à la fois prendre conscience des
risques de la portée du risque en les
mettant en fonction des différents
ateliers en situation d'accident donc
avec des simulations des chocs à des
vitesses des tonneaux un car scolaire
qui se couche mais également se
permettre de se connaître soi même une
quarantaine de partenaires a été
sollicité pour cette deuxième édition
pompiers médecine du travail ou encore
l'association
le port de la ceinture on la met
systématiquement ses rentrées dans notre
culture
le port de la ceinture tout le monde
même bébé ils savent à y mettre la
ceinture mais il la met mal on l'a mais
par peur du gendarme par réflexe mais on
l'a même aller ici savent pas que ça
doit être ça doit pas être dans des
parties moins lisse à pâques on doit
enlever les guides au lycée raconte
enlever le téléphone portable de la
proche ski bus et les cars périer c'est
lary 220 conducteur qui assurent 70
c'est un vis par jour
comme françoise qui transportent des
élèves depuis trois ans 14h30
quotidienne derrière un volant je vous
lance le test
la clio titienne vous les interpréter la
façon déjà de quitter sa place
la passion de se comporter sur la route
il ya des petites choses comme ça car on
se rend compte une journée dédiée aux
conducteurs de bus mais aussi les autres
salariés
74 % des accidents mortels ont lieu lors
de trajets quotidiens
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale
des pâtes
l'occasion de découvrir les secrets de
fabrication de cette spécialité
ancestrale venue d'italie
elle nous sommes allés à la rencontre
d'un italien chef de cuisine au
restaurant l'olive et au à montigny le
bretonneux manon varaldo et nicolas
landry
[Musique]
là bas les pattes c'est une religion
c'est le premier plat qu'on mange tous
les jours à midi
c'est le plat principal des italiens il
ya plein de types de pâtes des pâtes
farcies comme les raviolis les bat
longue comme les spaghettis les bugatti
nil et talia tel n'est pas par dell et
les chiens à la télé des pâtes courtes
comme les penne les farfal les rigatoni
[Musique]
là on a des châles at elle y est elles
viennent de la côte amalfitaine
ce sont des tailles est elle plus courte
et plus fine et l'est pas par des leçons
napolitaine ce sont des tags et tel film
est plus large
[Musique]
je suis en train de préparer des
stratégies nati avec de la farine de
l'eau du sel et après je fais reposer la
pâte pendant 30 minutes après ces trente
minutes
j'en fais des petites rondelles je les
coupe tous les trois centimètres après
avec trois doigts je vais créer la forme
de la pâte
il ya un trou à l'intérieur du coup
quand je vais les faire revenir avec la
sauce les pattes vont prendre leur goût
j'ai fais cuire les brocolis dans de
l'eau salée la même eau de cuisson que
les pâtes échalotes
une fois que c'est doré j'ajoute de la
saucisse fraîche et puis j'ajoute les
brocolis
[Musique]
et puis un mot de sport avant de vous
laisser on l'a appris ce matin la 21e
étape du tour de france partira une
nouvelle fois des yvelines après où il
en paces et rambouillet qui accueillera
le dernier départ de la grande boucle et
dimanche 28 juillet et 127 km direction
les champs elysées c'est la troisième
fois que la compétition cycliste passe
par la ville de rambouillet c'est la fin
du set 8 journal dans un instant le 7-8
loisirs se pare de son plus beau costume
d'halloween une émission spéciale
présentée par marylène iapichino belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]